Oh, heute ist Samstag. Dann kommt ja gleich mein Lieblings-Podcast.
Das waren die Nachrichten. Es folgt das Podcast UFO, eine Worst-Bird-Produktion mit Florian Willis und Stefflan Tötzmeister. Viel Spaß. Alles völlig richtig. Nichts falsch. Keine Anmerkung. Boah, Stefan, ey. Vielen Dank für diese Ankündigung, herzlich willkommen zur neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Das Podcast UFO. Wir haben die Leiter für euch ausgefahren, steigt gerne drauf, lasst die Schuhe bitte unbedingt an. Bitte unbedingt an. Weil ihr wollt nicht reintreten. Wir hatten hier so ein Leck, irgendwiegendwie so der Tank mit dem Zeug, ich weiß nicht ins Detail, was wir brauchen für Überschallgeschwindigkeit, ist ausgelaufen. Flotin hat es mal wieder irgendwie offen gelassen. Dann habe ich versucht, das mit so einem grossen Stroheim wollte ich so ansaugen. Und dabei habe ich es aber aus Versehen verschluckt. Flotin erbricht. Dadurch habe ich mich übergeben. Flotin erbricht. Dann habe ich mich in den Treibstoff hinein übergeben, dann hat sich das, weil Stefan ein bisschen rau gefahren ist, sage ich mal, ein bisschen rau gefahren ist. Ich wollte einfach nach Hause kommen und hatte zwei Bier getrunken. Ja, aber trotzdem, es war ein Asteroidengürtel. Aber es war nur zwei Bier, also und es war erlaubt. Ja, aber trotzdem, es war halt, ich weiss, es ist erlaubt, okay, es ist ein bisschen wild und dadurch hat sich halt der Treibstoff und mein erbrochenes. Nee, weil du es immer wieder ansprichst, so, ich habe kein Problem. Weil es in dem Moment einfach ein Problem war und deswegen meine ich ja. Ich habe kein Problem. Nein, aber in dem Moment war es ein Problem, weil es sich das Erbrochene und der Treibstoff zusammen vermengt hat. Dann habe ich versucht, dieses Gemisch nochmal mit dem Strohhalm aufzusaugen. Wir haben gesagt, wir müssen da nicht drüber reden jetzt. Ich verstehe nicht, warum du jetzt die ganze Geschichte mal wieder erzählst. Ich will nur sagen, früher haben wir immer gesagt, Schuhe aus, aber jetzt ist es irgendwann so gekippt, dass das Raumschiff so dreckig geworden ist, dass wir gesagt haben, nee, ab jetzt alle an. Es wird quasi sauberer, je mehr Dreck ihr raustragt mit euren Dreckschuhen. Genau, so, und das ist dann der Punkt, wo es kippt, vielleicht kippt es irgendwann wieder zurück. Wer weiß, vielleicht kippt es irgendwann wieder zurück. Ich fahr nicht scheisse. Nee, nee, du bist halt energisch. Ich fahr schnell.
Ja, du fliegst schnell.
Ja, aber du bist selber froh, wenn du dann am Heimatplaneten wieder bist. Ja, aber ich bin nicht froh, wenn mir dann irgendwie da alles durch die Gegend geworfen wird oder so. Ich habe mal letztens versucht zu schlafen hinten in der Kajüte drin, bin ich an der Decke aufgewacht. Da kann ja niemand schlafen, da klebt ja auch alles, wie der Mate. Ja, verklebt. Marte. Stefan,
aber es gibt
Punkte in der Welt, es gibt Punkte, da ändert
sich alles. Ich glaube zum Beispiel,
ich bin gerade
so ein bisschen im Investigativen drin, ich habe nämlich
gerade eine Reportage gesehen.
Eine, seit Jahren die erste, aber du bist
drin. Ich liebe
Reportagen.
Es gibt immer so, ich schaue Reportagen nur für so ein paar einzelne Momente. Eigentlich bräuchte ich so eine Compilation. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, immer nur die Szene, wo dann die Person merkt, dass sie... Der Mentor, die Mentorfigur kommt. Die Mentorfigur, genau. Und ihm sagt, nee, du bist der Ausgewählte. Richtig. In fact, du hast folgende Kraft. Oder wo die Haupt die Person merkt, dass sie ... Der Mentor, die Mentor-Figur kommt. Die Mentor-Figur, genau. Und ihm sagt, nee, du bist der Auserwählte, im Fact, du hast folgende Kraft. Oder wo die Hauptfigur merkt, dass sie eigentlich viel mächtiger ist, als sie dachte. So der Moment, wo die Kraft so ... Aber da kann uns vielleicht KI helfen. Da könnte uns auf jeden Fall KI helfen, dass er dann sagt, okay, gib mir all diese Szenen aus ... Weil, um ehrlich zu sein, und das tut mir echt jetzt ein bisschen leid für viele da draußen, aber ich hab wirklich festgestellt, ich bin kein Filmfan mehr. Das heisst nicht, dass ich keine Filme mehr schaue, aber für mich ist ein Fan, stopp, für mich ist ein Fan schon noch jemand. Ich werde weiter sarkastisch ausatmen, ob du das willst oder nicht. Für mich ist ein Fan jemand, der auch das Schlechte von dem Medium gerne annimmt und zelebriert und schaut und sagt, okay, ich schaue mir jeden Film an, der ins Kino kommt. Ich schaue mir pro Jahr den besten an, den schaue ich mir an, wenn ich also bin ich eigentlich kein Fan. So, wenn jemand sagt, ah, ich bin Filmfan, ah, was sind deine Lieblingsfilme? Ah ja, der Pate, Casablanca und Pulp Fiction, du bist kein Filmfan. Das sind halt die, weißt du, wenn du sagst, ich bin Essensfan, ja, was magst du, Pizza und Pasta Bolognese so, nee, das sind halt die besten ihrer Art, die über den des Fantum hinaus gut sind. Also musst du auch schlechte Sachen mögen, um Fan des Genres zu sein. Du musst das Genre an selbst, also wenn du jetzt Fan von klassischer Musik bist, dann musst du alle Sinfonien von Beethoven hören.
Auch die Scheisse von Herbert Schöpfer.
Auch die dumme Scheisse und die Dreckszweite Sinfonie von Beethoven, wo er aber richtig reingeschissen hat. Hä? Wo er mal richtig komplett richtig reagiert. Ich mag die, weil ich bin Klassikfan. So, genau. Und du musst sie dann schon mögen. Okay, ja, verstehe. Der Nicht-Fan darf selektieren. Der Fan hat sich entschieden, nicht selektieren zu dürfen. Fans haten, vergiss das mal nicht. Wichtige Fans haten, ich mag die auch nicht.
So, deswegen sage ich, wäre sowieso ein KI-Tool für mich perfekt, wo man sagt, hey, gib mir nur immer die Szenen, die ich mag.
So, und bei Reportagen ist es immer die Szene, wo sie hinter dem Täter herrennen, wo sie dann konfrontieren.
Und diese Szenen haben Nullwert. Ich habe noch nie eine Reportage gesehen, wo man sagt, hey, wir sind schon vor dem Spiegel, haben Sie unter dem so und so, haben Sie unter dem Verlag rechtsradikale Schriften veröffentlicht? Ich war's, ich sag alles, was ihr wissen wollt, endlich habt ihr mich, das Versteckspiel ist vorbei, ich war's, sorry, sorry, sorry, Abspann. Abspann der Doku. Whenever, whenever, whenever, meet together, when we hear, when we hear, when we hear. So, und nie bringt es was. Ich wäre so lustig, wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr darüber gesprochen hätten, sondern einfach offensichtlich wieder mal einen Grund suchten, whenever, wherever, whenever, whatever zu singen. Es bringt nie was, es ist alles verschwommen, es ist alles zens er wollte nicht er wollte nicht kommentieren aber er wollte keinen kommentar zu geben was selbst ja schon ein ausreichender kommentar ist und es bringt nie was aber trotzdem machen die das jedes mal wir werden also nie erfahren ob er daran schuld war oder todbringende aliens so die szene aus jeder reportage und die zweite szene die ich mag Reportagen, ist, wenn Dinge offensichtlich gefakt sind, was ja finde ich auch völlig in Ordnung ist. Du meinst Reenactments. Genau. Du meinst Reenactments. Und aber dann, was ich dann mag, ist, dass ich laut sage, das haben die ja nochmal nachgedreht. Ja. Weil was es oft gibt, ist die Szene zum Beispiel so. Auch wenn du komplett alleine bist? Absolut. Mag ich auch. Bei zum Beispiel so Betrugsfälle, da ist ja oft das Problem, dass es den Opfern peinlich ist und die reden nicht gerne über den Betrug, dass sie darauf reingefallen sind, auf irgendeinen Prinzen irgendwo und der in sie verliebt war und dann am Ende haben sie ihr ganzes Geld überwiesen. Das ist peinlich. Und das ist ja ein bisschen ein Problem für die Reportage, weil die wollen ja mit den Trotteln reden. werden Reportagen auch, also ganz, ganz oft, also sehr häufig werden sie in der Rückschau erzählt.
Und manche Sachen kann man schlicht nicht mehr zeigen, wie zum Beispiel Napoleon-Kriege.
Schwierig.
Richtigchau erzählt. Und manche Sachen kann man schlicht nicht mehr zeigen, wie zum Beispiel Napoleon-Kriege. Schwierig. Also macht man Reenactments und zeigt Dinge. Und da ist wichtig zu sagen, egal ob man alleine ist oder in einer Gruppe, alleine vor sich eben auch, man muss sagen, das haben sie nachgedreht. Richtig, das ist wichtig. Und was es oft gibt, ist, die investigative Reporterin ist dann auf dem Weg zu dem Opfer, dem Betrugsopfer. Im Auto. Und sagt dann so, ich habe jetzt schon oft mit ihr privat gesprochen und sie hat sich jetzt heute dazu bereit erklärt, auch vor der Kamera mir ein Interview zu geben. Und dann gibt es die Szene, die Reporterin läuft durch die Fussgängerzone, holt ihr Handy aus der Tasche, telefoniert und, ja, okay, das kann ich verstehen. Also sie hat mir jetzt gerade angerufen und hat gesagt, dass sie doch kein Interview... Und so hat sie abgesagt. Und wir wissen nicht, war es ihr eigener Antrieb oder stecken dahinter etwa todbringende Aliens. Und dann sage ich immer, naja, das werden sie nachgedreht haben. Weil die filmen ja nicht die Reporterin 24-7, bis sie den Anruf bekommt, sondern die sagt, oh scheisse, wir können den Termin nicht machen, ja, da lass uns kurz in die Fussgeräte-Zone gehen und das drehen. So, und dann sitze ich da und sage, ja, das haben die nachgedreht. Was, Schatz, was? Nein, nichts. Ich mache hier nichts laut, weil ich berate hier gerade was an. Nein, nein, das ist in Ordnung. Schaust du in die Dokus? Ja. Weil du sprichst ununterbrochen mit dir selber. Ja. So, und da dachte ich mir zum Beispiel auch, weil in den Dokus gibt es immer, und das mag ich auch als Stilmittel, Ricardo F. Es gibt immer Vorname, ein Buchstabe des Nachnamen, Punkt. Ricardo F., deutsch-deutscher Libanese mit libanesischem Pass. Deutsch-deutscher Libanese. Oder war es etwa der Deutsch-deutsche Libanese? Aber das ist immer so, Frederike C., Caroline B. und das hat schon so einen Klang. Wenn ich jetzt immer sagen würde, wie viele Buchstaben kann es geben, wow.
Wenn ich immer sagen würde, ja dann war ich ja unterwegs mit Stefan T, dann ist das so, oh, das ist ein Verbrecher, weil du bist so darauf konditioniert.
Und mittlerweile denke ich mir, es gibt so viele Nachnamen.
Ich glaube, wir können uns einen zweiten Buchstaben leisten.
Oh!
Hey, ohne Witz, ich glaube,
wir können sagen Stefan T. Das reicht. Aber das klingt wie das englische T. Das ist natürlich ein
problem es ist ein problem aber wenn du jetzt sagst du rikardo krill das kannst du sagen du weisst nicht krawatzky krevalsi kraboschek weisst du nicht du wärst wie in das nintendo-produkt ich
wäre florentin wie das ist kein problem Problem. Aber ich glaube, wir sind mittlerweile an einem Punkt, wo wir so viele Nachnamen haben. So viele verschiedene Nachnamen, es werden immer mehr. Weil wenn eins zunimmt, dann Nachnamen. Jeden Tag denkt sich irgendjemand einen neuen Nachnamen aus und sagt, Schatz, Florentin, was denn? Nachnamen nehmen dich zu. Niemand denkt sich Nachnamen mehr aus. Nachnamen sind endlich, wenn zwei Menschen sich ineinander verlieben. Ficken sie. Dann haben sie animalischen, schwitzigen Sex. Und währenddessen sagen sie, ja, jetzt ist mir der Name gekommen. Nein. Wir heissen Kraboczek. Nein, es werden sich keine Nachnamen ausgedacht. Es ist endlich, Nachnamen sind endlich. Es gibt jetzt, es gibt nie mehr Nachnamen als jetzt. Ausser, wenn Leute sich Buchstaben dazukaufen, was ich lächerlich finde, absolut politisch. Wenn sie leider in der finanziellen Notsituation sind, Buchstaben wieder verkaufen zu müssen. Damit sie auf dem Markt sind, weil es gibt nicht genug Buchstaben auf dem Markt. Es muss immer Gleichgewicht geben. Reiche spenden manchmal Buchstaben. Ja, genau. Deswegen Peter Thiel, der hieß der hieß eigentlich die den bringer so jetzt hat er irgendwann mehr nachbar ist er reich das ist sehr nett jeff bezos ist einfach besorowski jeffrey bezos ist er hat die hälfte einfach rausgehauen jeffrey carmichael bezosowski und überliegt ist jeff bezos ja noch Elon Musk Die ist nicht Elon Musk, die, Elon Musk, der hieß nicht Elon Musk, der hieß Elonomy Muskenson. Aber dankenswerterweise hat er viel für uns wirklich gemacht und die Buchstaben wieder zur Verfügung gestellt. So, wieder zur Verfügung gestellt. Manche haben sich aber immer kennengelernt, der hatte tatsächlich das E, ein E von Elon Musk im Namen. Wirklich? Das ist natürlich eine Ehre und schön, das dann Gold geschrieben war. Das ist schön, immer Capslog, immer gross geschrieben. So, deswegen gross geschrieben. Aber ist schon spannend, oder? Nachnamen sind nicht. Es sei denn, meine verschwinden vielleicht durch Doppelnamen, aber dann entsteht ja auch neu. Aber es verschwindet quasi einer. Wenn ich keine Kinder bekomme, ist wieder Name Tietze meines Stammes aussterben. Ist ja die Frage, ob irgendwann, also ich denke immer in die Zukunft und es gibt ja viele Leute, die... Du denkst mir viel zu viel an die Zukunft. Ich bin immer schon hundert Jahre weiter. Du denkst nie an die Vergangenheit. Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, war ich seltener. Und es gibt ja viele Leute, also die innere Präsenz spielt ja heute für viele Leute eine grosse Rolle. Und ich persönlich habe ja relativ oft mit Influencern zu tun oder so. Und dann trifft man sich, ja, auch mit dir, und dann trifft man sich und dann fragt man sich, ja, soll ich dich jetzt irgendwie Death Destroyer nennen oder Ricardo? Also wie soll man den ansprechen? Man weiss immer nicht genau, aber man kennt die Person nur durch ihren Nickname. Und da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass irgendwann diese Nicknames auch irgendwie offiziellen Status bekommen. Nachnamen werden, echt Mittelnamen werden, echte Namen werden oder irgendwann im Pass tatsächlich auch die Online-Präsenz stehen muss. Wir haben ja lange über die Klarnamenpflicht gesprochen, die ja zum Glück abgewiesen wurde von unserer ach so tollen Regierung. Aber ich fordere genau das Gegenteil, ich fordere, dass auch der Online-Name in den Personalausweis geschrieben werden muss. Ah, ah. Da steht dann Stefan Tietze, Esteban Tizios, ein zweiter Zeile, so dass die Kripo sofort wiss, ah, okay, Instagram-Kanal und so. Wann glaubst du, die Florentin will Prognoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseoseose Ausweisdokumente kommen? Ich glaube, 2031 ist es soweit. Noch ein paar Jährchen? Ihr habt jetzt noch die Gelegenheit, alle eure Accounts nochmal anzugucken, Frühjahrsputz zu machen. Voll boring bei mir, wenn es einfach Stefan Tietzel ist. Soll ich noch Honeymastard heissen, will ich wirklich noch Tongsmas heissen, sind das
alles gute Namen und dann irgendwann wirst du auf ein Formular tatsächlich deinen einen
Nickname hinschreiben müssen und der ist dann auch fest.
Die Florentin-Will-Poknose, Ose, Ose, Ose, Ose, Ose, Ose, Ose.
Und irgendwann wird es dann auch ein internationales Register geben, wo dann alle Nicknames drin sind und dann sind halt manche schon besetzt und dann musst du halt kleine X oder so unterstrich dazu machen. Aber ich meine nur, falls ihr an der Reportage sitzt im Schnitt, traut euch mal einfach den Nachnamen mit zwei Buchstaben zu geben. Sagt mal Stefan T. Stefan T. Bei mir, aber ich finde esöd. Bei mir hast du jetzt 20 Prozent des Namens geleakt mehr. Bei, bei, weiss nicht. Aber bei Tee. Faltermeier zum Beispiel ist der zweite Buchstabe weniger wert, arguably. Frederike F., Frederike Pfarr. Nee, weil du hast, es geht um die, ich finde es geht um die Prozentzahl des Nachnamens. Du meinst also, man sollte so zehn Prozent des Nachnamens preisgeben? Ja, weil, angenommen, du hast Young Lee. L-I als Nachname. Young und dann sagst du, dann würdest du dir die ganzen Nachnamen jetzt. Young Lee, zum Beispiel. Als Rapper oder was? Ja, oder irgendwie, weiss ich nicht. Okay. Y-A-N-G, Vorname, Lee, Nachname, L-I. Okay. Nach deiner neuen, ach so tollen These, die uns ja ich finde gut, dass du dir überhaupt an die wichtigen Dinge denkst bei uns, das bringt uns als Gesellschaft wirklich weiter, würdest du da den ganzen Namen leaken? Äh, ja. Ja, würde ich tun. Am Ende würde ich es tun. Deswegen meine ich, das geht nicht, du musst Prozente, da kannst du nicht den zweiten Buchstaben nehmen, sondern du musst beim ersten bleiben, weil dann würdest du, du darfst nicht mehr als 50% Nachnamen ziehen. Dann sagen wir mal 20%. Ab fünf Buchstaben Tizze ist dein ein Buchstaben. Das kannst du dann schon machen. Aber ich glaube, es würde nicht so viel ändern. Es würde wirklich nicht viel ändern. Weil letzten Endes, warum sagt man überhaupt den ersten Buchstaben des Nachnamens? Warum sagst du Ricardo F.? Name geändert. Name mehrfach geändert. Warum sagst du? Name so oft geändert, dass wir wieder beim Ursprungsnamen angekommen sind. Dass die Redaktion auch nicht mehr weiss, was der ursprüngliche Name ist. Wir konnten ihn seitdem nicht mehr erreichen. Name verloren. Name verschludert. Name von der Redaktion verloren. Aber auch so ernst, vorgetragen. Name von der Redaktion verschludert. Name von der Redaktion verschludert. Das finde ich sehr gut. Das würde bei uns passieren. Ich hab so Bock mal so eine Reportage zu machen, wo du so mal so richtig reinbohrst. Wir schludern! Ich kratze immer nur, ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ein Welten-Eiskunstläufer. Ich kratze immer nur so auf der Oberfläche und so. Sei froh! Ich will mal ein Maulwurf sein. Junge, sei froh! Du meinst, wenn man tief bohrt, kann man dann auch schlechtes finden. Wer tiefer schürft, der Böses finde. Habe ich letztens angeguckt, Eiskunstlauf, Olympiade, Olympia, irgendwas, was war da?
Eins von beiden, es ist entweder abwechselnd Olympiade und Olympia, also eins von beiden.
Habe ich gesehen, finde ich immer toll, ich mag es ja so einmal im Jahr so eine Sportart zu sehen, wie die dann hochspringen und drehen und da gibt es ja, weil es ist ja immer so verrückt, weil da gibt es, manche Tricks beim Eiskunstlauf sind verboten, zum Beispiel den Rückwärtssalto, den darfst du nicht machen, anscheinend weil er einfach zu gefährlich ist, weil Eis ist ja hart.
Die meisten Eiskunstläufer tragen, und das bedauere ich, keine Schutzkleidung. Die haben keinen Helm auf. Das wäre so hilarious, wenn die über ihre wunderschönen, geschneiderten, von den grössten Designern der Welt geschneiderten, engen Anzüge, dann wie so Karneval, Anorak, Anorak und Helm drüber haben, so ein Gesichtsschutz und dann diese Zahnschütze und dann sind die einfach aus so mit dem. Aber trotzdem super grazil und wunderbar elegant, aber immer halt mit diesen klobigen Sachen. Und diesen riesen Schienbein, wie so ein Eishockey-Torwart, schreien sie jetzt vor. Und deswegen gibt es keine Schutzkleidung, deswegen sind manche Sachen verboten, aber die Leute machen es trotzdem, einfach weil sie es können und da war zum Beispiel ein Eiskussläufer und der Kommentar, ich habe keine Ahnung von Eiskussläufer, der Kommentar hat gesagt, der war schon so weit hinten in der Bewertung, dass er gesagt hat, fuck it, ich mache den Rückwärtsalto. Obwohl ich Punktabzug kriege dafür. Du kriegst Punktabzug für manche Tricks, weil die verboten sind, aber er hat gesagt, ich mache es trotzdem. Und da denke ich mir, okay. Haut er da im dritten Inning einen Rückwärtssalto raus. Und jetzt ist meine Frage an dich, hat er jetzt Eiskunstlauf richtig verstanden oder gerade nicht verstanden? Ich finde, es ist ein Arschloch-Move. Oder lebt er den Sport richtig und sagt, bei Eiskunsteläufer hast du ja das Problem, dass es subjektiv ist, dass Leute das bewerten. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich gehe jetzt über mich hinaus bei Fussball, ich mache einen Flickflack und es ist ein ultra krasser Trick und es gelingt. Nee, du hast aber, finde ich, gerade als Eiskunstläufer hast du eine Vorbildfunktion. Das stimmt. Du trägst so viel Verantwortung, du bist ein Held von Milliarden Kindern da draußen.
Hunderte Eishallen in jeder Stadt.
Hunderte Milliarden Kinder da draußen, für die bist du einfach das Idol. Und wenn du diesen Rück, auch wenn du hinten liegst und du kannst nicht mehr verlieren, ein Rückwärtsalto machst, dann machen das alle nach. Du bist so ein Trend. Und das ist halt saugefährlich. Ich finde, das ist Eishockey nicht verstanden. Sorry, ich finde das Eiskunstlauf nicht verstanden. Ich finde es gut, dass sich das Thema offensichtlich so so hart langweilt, dass sein Kopfgedanklich schon zu dem viel cooleren Thema Eishockey übergegangen ist und man offensichtlich sieht, du würdest jetzt lieber über Eishockey reden.
Ich labere noch, aber mein Kopf ist schon ganz woanders. Also ich schaue es mir manchmal gerne an, aber ich stelle mir schon vor, jeder von, also ich stelle mir mal, ich versuche mir mal vorzustellen, um Respekt denen entgegenzubringen, versuche ich mir immer die wirklich hunderten, tausend Stunden vorzustellen, die das geübt haben. Und dann muss ich mir aber auch vorstellen, wie oft sind die auf dem Kopf gefallen. Also wie oft ist so ein professioneller Olympia-Athlet-Eiskunstlauf, wie oft ist der in seinem Leben einfach volle Lotte mit dem Kopf auf dem Kopf gefallen. fallen. Wahrscheinlich schon hundertmal oder dutzende mal? Die fangen ja nicht bei null an. Dutzende, dutzende? Ich denke mir, die fangen ja nicht bei null an. Ich denke mir, die fangen ja nicht bei null an. Das sind meine Five Cents dafür. Ich glaube, der fängt nicht bei null an. Wo fangen die an, wenn sie nicht bei null anfangen? Die meisten kommen ja aus dem Skispringen und oder andere Eis-related Sportarten. Ja, aus Schwimmball. Genau, also Wasser-Eis-Sportarten. Und die fangen ja dann nicht mehr nur an. Natürliche Progression von Wasser zu Eis, also Dampf, die meisten fangen ja erstmal Dampf an, Dampfsportart, dann natürlich Wasser und dann Eis, klar. Warum klingt Dampfsportart, als wäre das ein feststehender Begriff, den alle benutzen? Dampf, ach wegen Kampfsportart.
Ja, aber finde ich eine gute, also es gibt wenig, es gab vielleicht früher mal, als Dampf wirklich mal der heisse Scheiss war, Meersportarten.
Was ist das Wort?
Da gab es wahrscheinlich mehr Sportarten drumherum, also so Dampfschifffahrtsrennen oder so auf dem Mississippi oder so gab es ja bestimmt. Auf dem Me.
Und dann alle schnell reinschaufeln da. Ich musste gerade an denken, als du gesagt hast, wann kann die KI uns endlich zusammenschneiden, man bräuchte einen privaten Editor, der einem das schneidet, was man will. Und ich finde die Vorstellung so toll, dass man sich irgendwann auf die Couch setzt und die Brille aufsetzt und dann einen Film sieht wie man den will und du magst ja zum Beispiel Anfängen, Anfänge von Filmen, lieber als den zweiten Akt oder dritten Akt oder geschweige denn der vierte, der oft ein bisschen unnötige fünfte, davon wollen wir jetzt gar nicht als Anfang, aber der erste, den findest du am besten, dann wäre doch voll cool wenn du einfach so einen riesen langen ersten Aktfilm bekommst, der dann aufhört. Ich will, dass der Film endet damit, dass Spider-Man das erste Mal ein Netz schiesst. Genau. Und der Rest ist History. Was krimmelt da so in meinem Armgelenk? Handgelenk, Handgelenk. Wollen wir das nochmal machen? Schwarz, whenever, whenever beets your gas. Was springt die denn da in deinem Armgelenk? Verlenk, Brelenk, Gelenk? Das war der Film? Meine Hörte der Regisseur, wollen wir das nochmal machen? Abgeschnitten, wollen wir das nochmal machen? Ja, ich war, aber das sind halt dann so die Blupper. Bei den Special-Effekstypen hört man sagen, wir haben nur einen netten, und dann ist er abgeschnitten. Whenever,, whenever, whenever we'll be together. Aber das finde ich schon richtig gut. Aber ich meine, das Problem ist, aber wie funktioniert das mit dem Film? Ich habe mal einen fantastischen Tweet gelesen von amerikanischen Nutzer, den ich sehr mag. Mark Leggett heisst der, findet ihr bestimmt. Ich finde den absolut lustig. Und hat mal einen Tweet verfasst vor kurzer Zeit, er will sich ernsthaft auf die Kauche setzen, will die Brille aufsetzen und will dann einen Film sehen, wo Darth Vader, Hulk und sein Nachbar Dave gegen Wellen von Zombies ankämpfen. Welle after Welle, Welle. Wave after wave. eine neue Well wave, aber ich will auch die Dialogszenen zwischen die Wellen haben, aber dann weiss ich, es kommt immer eine Welle, mein Gehirn ist ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen, und der Film ist dreissig Stunden lang, mit Welle after Welle after Welle, after wave after Welle, ja, finde ich richtig gut. Ich meine, das Problem ist nur, legst du vor dem Film fest? Ich will Guido Kanz, dich und Hazel Brugger gegen Zombies. Hazel Brugger und ihr kämpft gegen Halbpferd, Halbfrosch Tiere. Okay. Und das ist für 10 Stunden mit Handlung natürlich auch. Ich will eine Love Story, nicht egal zwischen wem. Ich will nur den Anfang von dem Film sehen. Ach, das ist mir dann egal. Ich will, wenn man das erste Mal, wenn Hazel Boga so Hörst du da am Horizont? Ende. Das ist für mich zu Ende. Hä? Was ist bis dahin passiert in dem Film, wo es darum geht, dass ihr Wave after Wave after Welle bekämpft?
Es ist der erste Dialog vor der erste Welle. Aber also, liegst du denn vor dem Film fest oder ist der Film so mit deinem Kopf connected, dass der während du den Film siehst, merkst, oh, das ist gerade, die nächste Welle muss kommen, die nächste Welle. Du kommst nach Hause, will dich ausruhen, nimmst die Dose Bier aus dem Kühlschrank, machst die Chipstüte auf. Und dann musst du in dieses Denkarium, das ist dann einfach dieses grosse Wasserbecken, dann musst du so deine Haare zurück machen zu so einem Pferdeschons. In der Zukunft haben alle lange Haare, wunderschöne lange Haare. Und dann musst du deinen Kopf in diese gallartige Flüssigkeit stecken, Luft anhalten, für eine Minute. Das ist ein bisschen ein komischer Prozess, aber es war nicht anders möglich. Luft anhalten für eine Minute? Damit der einen Abdruck macht von deinem Gesicht, oder was? Nee, nee, und da misst es, da kommen so Elektroden rausgefahren, die siehst du ganz leicht, das sind ganz dünne Nadel in deinem Gehirn bohren. Ich muss mir was in den Kopf stechen lassen. Ja, willst du Welle after Welle sehen, wie heisst du, wie ein Bruder gegen Froschmensch kippt?
Ja, aber es gibt doch heute schon Elektroden, die du nur hinkleben musst. Ja, aber die können ja nicht einen Film machen. Du musst durch diesen Prozess. Manche denken, das ist ein Prank von dieser Firma. Ich gehe da jedes Mal gerne durch. Die wollen unser Blut oder was? Die Hände, die Haare ganz schön zusammen machen und dann hin und dann misst es deine Gegenfrequenz, worauf du jetzt gerade in diesem Moment Lust hast. Die Laufzeit des Films, welche Figuren machen mit, willst du Action, willst du Romantik, willst du Froschmännchen kämpfen gegen Hazelbrugger? Okay, aber sobald dieser Scan durch ist, wird der Film gemacht und dann schaust du den Film. Genau, dann schaust du Hazelbrugger gegen Froschmännchen. Weil ich denke mir nämlich, ich würde nämlich ein Gerät machen, das während des Films noch die ganze Zeit guckt und dann anpasst. Und ich sag mal so, jetzt ist es ja jetzt, glaube ich, ein menschliches Phänomen, dass wenn einem manchmal vielleicht in dem Film ein bisschen langweilig wird oder generell einfach, wenn man nicht so viel zu tun hat, dann schweifen die Gedanken ja manchmal durchaus in sexuelle ab. Also willst du immer in Hayser-Brucker-Frosch-Porn? Ich könnte mir mal vorstellen, dass man dann irgendwie so einen Film schaut, Forrest Gump oder so, Forrest Gump, Spider-Man und irgendwann...
Und deine Freundin guckt so mit dir den Film? Brugger Frosch Porn. Ich könnte mir mal vorstellen, dass man dann irgendwie so einen Film schaut, Forrest Gump oder so, Forrest Gump, Spider-Man und irgendwann...
Und deine Freundin guckt so mit dir den Film und irgendwann so, Flotin, Flotin, Flotin, Flotin, weil Forrest sich wieder anfängt auszuziehen.
Forrest Gump macht den Gürtel auf.
Und man denkt, ja, mein Gott, wir sind alle nur Menschen. Ich meine, irgendwann geht das alles ineinander über so.
Aber so spannend, was du gerade sagst. In dem Moment, in dem ja Filme nur für dich existieren, gibt es ja auch keine Scham mehr. Es gibt ja eh keine Schauspieler oder irgendwas mehr, das ist ja eh alles nur Bullshit, der generiert wird, es gibt ja keine Pornodarsteller mehr. Und dann musst du dich ja auch nicht dafür schämen, dass du dann Porno anschaust, weil niemand weiss, dass du den geschaut hast. Ja, außer die grosse Erektion, die man vorne in deiner Hose sieht. Ja, aber wir müssen mal nicht übertreiben, das ist überschaubar. Aber gibt es eine Art Cookie? Ich finde es ja super spannend, was es gerade macht. Also, wenn der Film fertig ist. Ich dachte ja, du bist in diesem Denkarium, hast deine Haare schön. Wo kommt denn dieses Wort her? Also das erste Mal dachte ich, okay, ich lasse es ihm durchgehen. Aber Denkarium, hast du gerade so ein Young Adult Novel gelesen, wo irgendwie die in so einem Denkarium zur Schule gehen und sich kennenlernen?
Wer sagt es ihm, Leute da draußen? Alle wissen, woher es kommt. Wer sagt es ihm?
Genau, also man guckt in dieses Denkarium rein und dann...
Denkarium oder Denkarium?
Denkarium ist er nämlich versprochen. Don't call me out.
Und dann brauchst du so drei, vier Tage, bis der Film fertig gerendert hat. Oh Gott. Also ich pikse mich und drei Tage später schaue ich denn, was ich vor drei Tagen wollte. Reinkommt raus, dass Tausend Inder diesen Film gedreht haben. Moment mal, dem ist gerade die Hazel-Brugger-Maske vom Kopf gerutscht, ist da ein Inder da hinter?
Tausend Inder haben diesen Film, aber genau tausend Inder haben diesen Film, wir finden Jobs für jeden einzelnen. Es gibt so ein Büro in Mumbai, wo die alle vor so einem Faxgerät stehen und dann kommt das Fax, schnell, schnell und dann okay, alles klar, du spielst Hazel Brugger, du spielst Frostmonster, schnell, schnell, schnell und dann müssen sie anfangen zu drehen. Genau, aus dem Denkarium kommt das Fax heraus und sie fangen an zu drehen. Aber ich finde es super spannend, was passiert mit Filmen, wenn sie sozusagen in Echtzeit reagieren könnten. Das ist wirklich super spannend. Und will man das, weil dann gibt es ja keine Spannung, weil du denkst, oh, wer ist der Mörder? Ich bin der Mörder! Ne, will man nicht, sieht man nicht genau den Film, den man gerade sieht, weil die meisten Filme sind ja wahrscheinlich, wie Menschen eh schon von Anbeginn der Menschheit sich Geschichten erzählt haben, nämlich mit einem Anfang, Mitte, Ende, Spannungsbogen, der ist normal, die Formen wie gerade Filme sind, die befriedigendste für den Menschen und deswegen hat sich die herauskristallisiert und was du guckst ist sozusagen. Ich glaube, das ist genau andersrum. Ich glaube, die Kultur existiert, um die Natur in Grenzen zu halten. Zum Beispiel Nachtisch. Nachtisch gibt es nach dem Essen. Würde man so essen, wie man will, würde man sich sofort, also ausser du, weil du bist komplett bescheuert und magst keine süssen Sachen, würde man sofort den Schokokuchen essen und dann erst die Gemüsesuppe. Aber die Kultur hat schlauerweise gesagt Nein, also erstens ist es tatsächlich auch gesünder, zweitens ist es die kultur die sagt nein deine deine gelüste müssen kontrolliert werden und spannung muss aufgebaut werden damit es geht und genau so funktioniert geschichten ab und ich glaube immer den schluckerkuchen zuerst gegessen haben die andertaler die den schluckerkuchen oder die den zimbeer sorbet zuerst gegessen haben sind im lauf der zeit verschieden also du meinst es Es gab ein Neandertaler-Stamm, du meinst ein Neandertaler-Stamm hat direkt Panna-Cotta gegessen und die anderen haben gesagt, wie Panna-Cottas, was so viel heisst wie erst nach dem Mammutschenkel, bitte erst nach dem Mammutschenkel, dann konsumieren, ja. Kann gut sein, aber ich weiss nicht, man sagt ja oft so, wenn Filme so gemacht werden, wie es das Publikum will, dann werden es schlechte Filme. Das sagt man literally die ganze Zeit. Einmal am Tag. Oft schon vormittag. Ja, ich hasse es. Ich sage es oft schon vormittag, manchmal auch einfach, damit es raus ist. Ja. Damit es raus ist und damit ich einfach da wieder dabei bin. Ja, das sagst du so gerne wie, das haben sie nachgestellt. Das mussten sie nachdrehen. Das haben sie nachgedreht. Das haben sie. Ich finde das immer so gut, man sagt oft sowas, das haben sie. Ja, das haben sie ja. Und dieses sie ist auch so, wer ist dieses sie genau. Bei Autobahnen haben sie wieder eine Baustelle jetzt hier gemacht. Wer sind diese verschwörerischen ss? Das machen sie, um mehr Geld zu verdienen. Wer? Wer? Sie. Sie. Und irgendwo ist Doktor Sie, der alles kontrolliert und der überall seine Finger mit drin hat. Und ich bin Se. Das Haus haben Sie jetzt abgerissen. Wer, wer sind Sie? Haben Sie schon mal Se gesagt? Ja, erst gestern, ich bin in diesem Haus vorbeigekommen und habe gesagt, das haben Sie abgerissen. Dann kennen Sie mich. Sie haben das Haus abgerissen? Ich Ich hab dasus abgerissen ich bin se doktor se ja und ich bin sein assistent und ich bin sein assistent hamse haben sie da haben sie da ist das mundart ist Das kann ja nicht sein. Okay, ich muss vorlesen. Gott sei Dank, Content, vielen Dank für Content. Caveat Theater. Okay, cool. Oh, guck mal, wir waren in New York beim Caveat Theater und da kriegt man ständig auch Nachrichten und zwar David Cross ist back. Wo war er? Er war weg, aber er ist zurück. Den haben sie versteckt. Keiner. Den wollten sie ja. Chassen. Den wollten sie ja chassen. Und das tut natürlich immer total weh, weil wir sind nicht in New York. All diese coolen Shows können wir nicht sehen. Ach, der Chassen tut weh. Hier, New Kids on the Blockchain zum Beispiel. Ja, das Caviar Theater, da gibt es ganz tolle Comedy-Shows in New York, wenn ihr da seid. Besucht es. Aber krass, weil du kriegst ja so bestimmt minütlich so 10.000 Spam-Mails. Also dass da jetzt eine zum ersten Mal überhaupt eine normale dabei war, ist ja eigentlich relativ unwahrscheinlich, oder? Ja. Kann ja jemand da draußen mal ausrechnen. Ach Mensch, jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Sehnsucht. Nach New York! Ach Mensch, ein schöner Bagel. Ein schöner Bagel in New York. Ein schöner Bagel oder so, eine schöne Stand-Up-Comedy-Show oder so, ein Musical oder so. Ein Musical. Kannst ja schön auf dem Broadway, kann es ja schön anschauen. Ey, wir haben Musical zu Hause, Florentin. Ach ja, jetzt bin ich irgendwie... Melancholisch? Jetzt bin ich melancholisch und sehnsüchtig. Das ist irgendwie gar nicht der richtige Zustand für so einen ... Nee, ist okay. Ey, nee, nee, Florentin, hör auf, hör auf. Ich finde, man kann ja auch mal Emotionen zeigen und mal ehrlich sein und mal authentisch und nicht immer nur so, ha ha lustig, lustig, wie wär's denn, wie du kannst folgendes moderiert hier lustige, hier lustige Show einfügen. Weißt du, das mal kurz weil das stört mich ein bisschen dass wir immer nur quatschig sind und nie mal auch mal ernster füreinander reden so und wenn du jetzt sagst du das sehnsucht dann finde ich es schön dass du mal deine emotionen mitteilst in der echten weil ich weiß ja gar nicht was bei dir los ist man ja weil du hast vorhin hast du ja schon bemerkt dass ich oft gedanklich in der zukunft bin und na ich bin ein progressiver Typ. Ja. Aber dann habe ich oft das Gefühl, dass ich nicht bei mir bin, weil ich immer denke, oh, ein paar Monaten ist das, oh, der neue Dota-Patch, oh, Sommerurlaub, die neue Sendung von Guido Kanz, aber ich bin irgendwie nie bei mir. Ich bin irgendwie gedanklich immer weit weg. Du willst ja den neuen Dota-Patch, Dota-Patch. Ja, aber es ist Dota. Dota. Nee, Dota. Oder wie ich mir vorstelle, D-O-T-E-R. Weil ich das noch nie schriftlich gesehen habe. Aber es ist so, Harald Lesch hat mal gesagt, alt ist man dann, wenn man mehr Freude an der Vergangenheit als an der Zukunft hat. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, oh, da ist was dran.
Und ich möchte nicht alt werden. Ich möchte immer freudig in die Zukunft gucken und nicht sagen, ach Mensch, früher, da haben wir noch, da standen wir auf der Bühne, Mensch, Live-Podcast, Stefan, Backstage, in Wien. Nein, ich möchte nach vorne gucken und sagen, ja, bald kommt der neue D wir sind bei der tour also ist nicht in diesem projekt aber wir freuen uns sehr euch zumindest sagen zu können ist es in dieser stimmung jetzt in der wir sind aber wir machen eine improv tour also tiz und will ja dagegen ende des jahres genau also so ab september geht's los und Tickets bekommt ihr auf tizundwill.de, ihr habt ja auch schon bei Instagram was gesehen, wir machen eine Tour, das wird richtig lustig, wir improvisieren, hat nichts mit dem Podcast zu tun, wir improvisieren auf Basis eines Wortes, eine Anmerkung aus dem Publikum eine Show und das hat wirklich, ich betone das, weil ich sehe schon die Hände, die hochschnellen und fragen, hat das was mit diesem Podcast zu tun? Die einzige Verbindung ist, dass wir beide sind. Wir beide sind dabei, sonst inhaltlich hat es nichts damit zu tun. Aber ich freue mich drauf. Guck mal, das ist ein Ereignis in der Zukunft, auf das ich mich sehr freue, wo ich sage, okay, das wird cool. Auch ein bisschen Angst, weil wir haben das so ein bisschen für uns gemacht, im kleinen Rahmen so, und jetzt sehr viel Angst. wir mit vieler wartungshaltung was bei improv natürlich immer so ein bisschen schwierig ist aber schaut vorbei auf tize will tize und will de das sollte man da sollte man sich mir mühe geben das richtig auszusprechen oder auf unserem instagram account tize und will entweder ihr seht eine gute show oder ihr seht uns richtig scheitern beides und beides ist ja auch eine art interessant ich. Beides spannend, wenn man nicht, wie wir selber sind, ist. Also mal so jemanden richtig scheitern, würde ich sagen, um Boden zu sehen. Ja, wann wirklich live, wie 60 Minuten lange reines Scheitern. 29 Euro zahlen für jemanden, um den richtig scheitern zu sehen, bin ich ehrlich. Es ist ja super leicht, Exzellenz zu sehen. Du schaust dir irgendwelche Schauspiel- und Filme an oder Sportler oder so, die Besten der
Besten sind omnipräsent, aber mal
wirklich jemanden, so ein Durchschnitt,
so ein unteres Durchschnitt,
in seiner Kunstform
und dann so selbstbewusst auch
mit Publikum und dann so
in seiner Kunstform, der so
unteres Mittelfeld ist. Genau,
das ist ja mal was Besonderes. Dafür würde ich zahlen. Ja, absolut. Ja, da bist du ja direkt dabei. Ja, ne, sind wir wirklich. Aber wo du sagst, älter werden, ich habe ein Problem, dieses Jahr werde ich nämlich 30 Jahre alt. Oh. Und ich bin ja immer noch, ich denke immer noch, ich werde 19. Du bist der ewige 19-Jährige, ja. Weil das immer so das Alter war, in dem irgendwie ich gepiekt habe und alle über mich gesagt haben, ah, der neunzehnjährige. Und jetzt ist so, werde ich da auch schon halt dreissig, ne? Bisschen uncool. Und dann weiß ich nicht, wie ich damit umgehen soll. Fallst du, ist dann... Ja, klar, also Einleitung habe ich schon auch rausgeschickt und alle und geht... Echt? Okay, cool, weil ich habe gar nichts. Ach so. Das war die alte Mail oder was? Hast du meine neue Mail? Ah, dann ging es wohl eine alte Mail ran. Ach so, nee. Ach so, dann gucke ich mal bei der alten. Äh, ne, habe ich jetzt gar nicht bekommen. Wie sagst du, alte Mail zu einem, wo du noch den Accounts übernommen hast. Habe ich jetzt gar nicht bekommen. Ah, okay, dann ging es wohl an der Post, mit der Post ging die raus. Sorry, habe ich mich jetzt, mit der Post ging die raus. Ach so, ja. Ah, ja, okay, ich war schon eine Weile nicht mehr. Guck mal zu Hause. Genau, du warst schon eine Weile nicht mehr zu Hause. Wo bist du denn? Ich bin ja zu Hause die ganze Zeit. Ja, ja, genau, schau da einfach mal nach. Aber ich meine, um 30 ist halt auch ein krasser, vielleicht feiere ich auch gar nicht, ein krasser Geburtstag irgendwie. Ach so. Und ich habe mich gefreut, wie du mit klargekommen bist, als du heftig geworden bist. Ja, ich sage mal so, ne, also das ist schon ein Einschnitt, ne, das ist schon was anderes. Mit dem machst du was gar nichts, das ist meine These. Ich glaube, wir sind uns ja gar nicht so unähnlich, weil tatsächlich war es, ich galt auch oft als der Jüngste, tatsächlich, zum Beispiel in der Frank-Elsa-Masterclass war ich der Jüngste und es war dann immer so, der Junge, ah, du bist natürlich, ah, krass, ich bin ja acht Jahre älter, urkrass und das ist einerseits natürlich, man freut sich charmant, denkt sich, hey, ich bin, ich kann mit denen mithalten, und ich bin jünger, dann bin ich besser, weil wenn ich so alt bin wie die, bin ich ja noch krasser, das ist einfach, fühlt sich gut an. Ja. Und wenn man aber zu lange in diesem Ding drin ist und irgendwann es nicht mehr hat, dann denkt man sich, oh shit, ich bin nicht mehr der Jüngste.
Nisthäckchen. Oh, ich bin ja nicht mehr im Ansatz, oh shit, der ist zehn Jahre jünger als ich und der ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ja. Der, der, der kann wiederum mit mir mithalten, wo bin ich dann so und deswegen glaube ich, ist es eine blöde Situation, wenn man immer als der Jüngste galt, dann plötzlich irgendwann das nicht mehr zu sein, weil dann hat man das Gefühl, man hat nicht mehr diesen Vorsprung, als der Jüngste hat man denkt man immer, ich habe ja den Vorsprung, ich habe ja dieses Kissen noch, aber irgendwann hat man es nicht mehr und dann denkt man, okay, was ich jetzt habe, ist es. Vor allem kommt man in dieses Alter, wo viele Leute, die jung erfolgreich waren, ihre besten Werke schon gemacht haben. Ja, oder schon tot waren. Ja, aber so ein Schubert, der wäre tot in zwei Jahren. Oder so ein Paul Thomas Anderson hat mit 28, ist schon vorbei bei mir, Boogie Nights gemacht. Wow, krass. Also die Einstiege werden halt so krass. Aber du hast ja jetzt auch schon einiges gemacht, Stefan. Also so ist es nicht, dass du jetzt noch ganz am Anfang bist. Ja, aber das Magnum Opus ist ja auch nicht Boogie Nights. Also dein Magnolia kommt ja noch, sag ich mal. Kommt auch noch ein There Will Be Blood oder bin ich dann schon tot? Aber wir müssen mal nicht betreiben.
Also du hast Talende, aber...
Talende?
Talende.
Ja, ich weiss auch nicht.
Mensch, Stefan, ja, aber du bist ja auch gereift, ne?
Also du hast dich ja auch echt...
Nee, ich muss ja da denken, weil das ist, glaube ich, die unangenehmste Art von Nachrichten, die man kriegen kann.
So von random Leuten auf Instagram.
Du bist gereift. Hey Florentin, ich finde, du hast dich in den letzten zwei Jahren richtig toll entwickelt. Liegt wahrscheinlich auch an deinem Privatleben. Und man denkt sich so, was? Es ist so total nett und alles positiv, aber das ist so eine merkwürdige, du hast dich in den letzten und dann so ein merkwürdig spezifischer Zeitraum so. Ey, du hast dich in den letzten 18 Monaten richtig toll entwickelt.
Ich kann das nicht wirklich als positiv auffassen.
Bist du dann in den Kalender gegangen und hast du überlegt, was ist da passiert?
Genau, was war da?
Und dann ist da so, Arzttermin.
Moment mal, da habe ich Flabber gesehen.
Hat mich das ... Hat mich das nochmal aus anderen ...
Du bist aus dem Kino gegangen, wo das gezeigt wurde nochmal.
Ja, genau.
Und du hast gesagt, dieser Film hat mich verändert, hast du gesagt.
Aber es ist ein, was. Aber ich wusste, irgendwas in mir hat angefangen, wie so ein Domino-Effekt, Domino Day, so der erste Domino-Stein. Domino mit drei M, ne? Ja, ja. Mein Gott, ey. Doch,ucking Dominos, ne?
Wirst du jetzt zum Pedanten, wenden sich jetzt unsere Rollen im Podcast so ein bisschen, dass du so zum grantigen Alten wirst?
Aber ich habe mal die Nachricht bekommen, vor gar nicht so langer Zeit,
Hi Stefan, irgendwie, ich habe alte Folgen gehört und jetzt mal in eine der neueren reingehört.
Und es ist so krass, wie reingehört.
Und es ist so krass, wie du dein Nudelproblem in den Griff bekommen hast. Das ist sehr inspirierend, vielen Dank. Ja, ähm, Glückwunsch! und dann meine frage das ist so wie ich hätte die ganze zeit in basilikum blatt zwischen den
zähnen und ihr sagt mir das jetzt wo es weg weg ist, dass ich toll aussehe ohne Basilikumblatt zwischen den Zähnen. Wenn jemand etwas schalt... Damals hat niemand von euch da draußen gesagt, Stefan, krieg mal ein Nuschelproblem in den Griff. Ihr habt alles einfach akzeptiert und geschwiegen. Wenn man es schon geschafft hat, muss man es auch nicht mehr sagen so. Wenn das Basilikumblatt weg ist, dann ist es weg. Passt schon. Ihr habt geschwiegen. Setz Schlaf. Ohrenbetäubendes Schweigen. Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie du dich veränderst. Du bist natürlich ein Mensch, der durch seine Veränderung auffällt. Du bist Stefan das Chamäleon, du bist immer jemand anders. Vielleicht ist 30 für dich mal eine Zeit, einen Anker zu werfen. Ich muss mal ankommen. Du musst mal wirklich ankommen. Vielleicht mal einen Hafen finden, will ich mal anlegen. Ich meine, Anker werfen ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, also hilft nicht unbedingt. Wie kommt es dann aufs Schiff? Kommt darauf an, wo du wohnst. Kommt darauf an, ob du auf dem Schiff, also kommt darauf an, wo du wohnst und wo du bist. Wenn das Schiff jetzt schon am Hafen ist. Aber Anker werfen klingt so wie so ein Zwischen-Zwisto. Ein Anker gibt Halt. Klar, klar anker hält dich auch zurück erhält dich weiter ja du bist schatz du bist mein anker ja das ist nicht positiv du hältst mich an ort und stelle fest ich würde gerne nach berlin ziehen aber du bist mein schatz du bist wirklich mein anker ja ich will der der wind ist stark aber du bist mein anker okay das klingt wieder würde mich gleich... Dass man nicht wegzieht, okay. Und das würde ich gerne machen dieses Jahr eigentlich noch. Und dann hätte ich gern irgendwann mal so im Alter so ein eigenes Bödelchen, an dem man so rumbergelt. Und mit Alter meinst du dann 38 oder was? Und dann will ich im Alter mit so knochigen, aber noch rustikalen 38, will ich dann irgendwie mal so nach Übersegeln zu den Ferroer-Inseln oder Schottland.
Ja, nimm uns mit, aber ist ja spannend, dass du in dem Jahr, in dem das Podcast UFO ziehen wird, wirst du 30.
Ein Drittel deines Lebens machst du genau den Podcast schon.
Ja, das ist wirklich absurd.
Das ist schon echt krass.
Das ist wirklich absurd. Ein Drittel meines Lebens.
Drittel.
Vor allem, das ist ja wie ein Tagebuch, man kann auch zurückhören. Oh ja. Und dann merkt man die Veränderung eines Menschen. Das Podcast-Ufo oder die Veränderung eines Menschen. Also wir waren, das war 50-50, wie der Podcast heissen soll. Die Veränderung eines Menschen. Du bist eine Konstante. Wir haben überlegt, entweder zwei Mikrofone, zwei Gesichter, das Podcast-Ufo oder die Veränderung des Menschen. Eines Menschen. Aber da dachten wir wegen dem Ä ist das mit der Domain nicht so gut. Ja, Florentin, du bist mein Anker. Ach, da, hm. Ja. Guido Kanz, wie wäre es mit, wenn er so eine Kochshow machen würde, oder? Die Kochshow. Kochshow, na stell dir mal vor, fünf Sterneköche kriegen. Moment, Moment, fünf, fullstop, Sterneköche. Köche, ja, fünf Sterneköche. Hör auf, das soll so sagen. Also, du hast fünf Sterneköche, zwei oder drei, du hast eine beliebige Anzahl fünf Sternekirche. Je nachdem, wie viele zusagen. Ich glaube, man kann nur drei haben. Sterne. Du hast fünf drei Sternekirche. Genau. So, und jetzt ist der Twist, die kriegen alle ein minderwertiges Produkt. Pedantenhand, pedant, pedant. Ja, bitte, Stefan. Das Restaurant kriegt Sterne, nicht der Koch. So, und dann hast du eben fünf Köcher aus drei Sterne, Restaurant, Störe, Restaurant. Und der Twist ist, die kriegen irgendein minderwertiges Produkt. Sagen wir mal so. Maggi. Ja, die kriegen so diese Tortellini, die man so fertig kaufen kann aus so in so plastik so und daraus müssen die jetzt ein drei sterne gericht zaubern sozusagen die basis ist schlecht also man sagt ja immer warum ist das essen so gut ja die zutaten sind es ja es braucht immer die zutaten und da soll jetzt auch mal bewiesen werden nein ein guter koch kann auch aus schlechten zutaten was feines kochen. Okay, und Guido Kanz testet das, alles isst sich durch. Guido Kanz verbindet den Prominenten die Augen, da ist er bei Barbara, da schöne Berger. Ganz kurz, vielen Dank an alle, die die Google-Suchanfrage, Guido Kanz eingefroren, nach oben gejazzt haben bei Google. Yes, yes, so gut, ey. Ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch da steht, aber war eingefroren. Wir haben nämlich die Theorie aufgestellt, dass er vielleicht ... Und auch in unserem Reddit wurde auch ein Bild gepostet, wie er in so einer Eiskammer unterwegs ist. Sehr, sehr gut. Also haltet das aufrecht. Also nicht mehr zu sehen. Jetzt nur noch Jung, AfD, Kinder, Vermögen, Porsche, Auto, Kochbuch, Bücher, Haare oder Karneval 2024. Also googelt bitte weiter, Guido Kanz eingefroren. Googelt mal Guido Kanz aufgetaut. Schon aufgetaut? Oder wann, wann wird Guido kann's auftauen wenn man jetzt den stecker ziehen würde wann so und guido kann's verbindet den prominenten die augen und dann müssen die das essen und sagen was am besten geschmeckt hat moment die sind auch noch prominent stopp fünf Normalos. Die fünf Sterne-Köche kriegen ganz schlechte Zutaten. Du musst genau sein. Bitte, in den Pitch ist genau sein. Fünf Drei-Sterne-Restaurant-Köchen. Die fünfzehn Sterne-Köche kriegen ganz minderwertige Zutaten, sind aber gute Köche. Die fünf Normalos, vielleicht sogar auch im Publikum, einfach rausgeholt. Die Clara,
Rebecca, Vanessa.
Ja, das ist geil.
Man fragt so lange Namen ab,
bis man genau fünf davon im Publikum hat. Also, Thomas!
Acht Leute melden sich.
Nein, Guido Gans schüttelt den Kopf,
damit es alle sehen können.
Vanessa! Fünf, bitte, lass abkürzen. Lass das abkürzen. Fünf, Gott sei Dank. Puh, Gott sei Dank bei der zweiten Frage. Ja, Guido Kanz nickt. Dann kommt auf die Bühne. Alle fünf Vanessa, so. Und dann hast du ja Vanessa gegen Fünf-Sterne-Köche. Genau, spart man sich Einblendungen. Total. Nee, aber Gu Guido kannst es ja nicht, der sagt bei jeder nochmal, und wie heisst du? Vanessa. Diese Sendung ist so langatmisch. Und das Publikum lacht jedes Mal. Und wie heisst du? Ja, ich heisse Vanessa. Und wie heisst du? Publikum lacht schon in Erwartung, weil es das weiss. Und dann aber Guido kannst bei der letzten sagt er dann, hallo Vanessa. So, da bricht das dann. Und die Idee ist, die Vanessas kriegen ganz, ganz gute Zutaten, da gibt's Hummer und Meeresalz und Cayenne.
Wir haben Hummer, Hummer, Hummer, haben Hummer, Hummer, Hummer, haben Hummer, Hummer, Hummer, Hummer, Schnapp, schnapp, schnapp.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, Normalos mit guten Zutaten oder profis mit schlechten zutaten wäre es besser das ganze sieht augen verbunden ja glaube ich habe verbunden ich glaube die konsistenz die die sterneköche hinkriegen werden ist unglaublich temperatur spaß konsistenz hier Da crackt es vielleicht ein bisschen, ich glaube, deswegen sollte man sich, man sollte es gar nicht essen. Ja, aber guck mal, genau solche Leute wie du schauen die Sendung, weil sie das wissen wollen, weil sie wissen wollen, was ist am Ende wichtiger, die Zutaten oder der Koch.
So das Ganze heisst, Zutaten oder Koch, Untertitel, Schmatz, Schmatz, Schmatz, Die Veränderung des Menschen. Die Veränderung des Menschen. Unter Untertitel, Guido, kannst die Show. Unter Untertitel, bitte nicht absetzen. Unter Untertitel, bitte hinsetzen. Unter Unter Untertitel, Leonie, ich würde es nochmal versuchen, wenn du willst, ich bin bereit. Ruf mich an, nur ein Sie. Ich ruf mich. Ich ruf mich an. Ich ruf mich an. Ich ruf mich an. Ich ruf mich an. Ich ruf mich an. Also guck mal, Guido, sobald du wieder aufgetaut bist, ruf uns an, wir haben viele, viele Ideen. Könnt ihr Guido Kanz aufgetaut googeln, weil das impliziert noch mehr. Das impliziert ja auch, dass er aufgetaut, dass er auch eingefroren war. Es impliziert, dass er für eine unbestimmte Zeit eingefroren war, jetzt aber wieder aufgetaut ist. Es ist so eine verheissungsvolle Veränderung. Angenommen, ich will, dass irgendwie so eine Renate58 guckt, was gibt es gerade für Guido-Kanzler, sie ist Fan, googelt ihn, es kommt aufgetaut, was das alles impliziert. Es ist impliziert, dass er eingefroren war, weil nur eingefroren, das war lustig. Vielen Dank nochmal an alle Daraus, die mitgemacht haben und das zu einer krassen Vervollständigung gemacht hat. Aber es impliziert nicht so viel, nur dass er sich einfrieren lassen und es geschieht vorbei. Das ist ja klar, das macht man halt, wenn man so viel Geld hat. Aber während Lebzeiten dann doch wieder aufgetaut, das ist schon gut. Ich finde, aufgetaut und dann die Frage, ach, deswegen war er weg, wie eingefroren und warum jetzt hat er sich auftauen lassen, weil jetzt was passiert. Und wer hat die Entscheidung getroffen oder hat er gesagt, wenn X passiert, bitte taucht mich auf. Gibt es Hörer von euch, die bei der Bild arbeiten, haben wir Maulwürfe bei der Bild, könnt ihr vielleicht so im letzten Moment, so wenn das PDF geschickt wird an die Druckerei, so im letzten Moment die Schlagzeile ändern, den Guido Kanz aufgetaut, Ausrufezeichen. Nichts, kein Text. Das Bild würde ich da gar nicht verändern, was auch immer da halt ist. So und deswegen kurz bevor es in die Druckerei geht und dann einfach mal ganz Deutschland Guido-Kanz aufgetaut, das fände ich geil. Und mir gefällt auch, dass, weil Einfrieren klingt noch so leicht, I don't know, wissenschaftlich jetzt nicht, aber das klingt so, als wäre es der Prozess, aber das ist auch, dass wir auch das wie Essen das Wort auftauen benutzen, bei diesem oft, ich stelle mir jetzt vor, chemisch komplexen Vorgang des Wieder, weiß ich nicht, ins Leben bringen, aber das auch auftauen. Ja, auftauen. So, als erstes so die Finger so ein bisschen und dann immer mehr und dann zuckt er wieder. Zuckt. Wie lange habe ich geschlafen? Drei Monate oder so. Was, drei Monate? Ja. Haben wir schon fliegende Autos und sich selbst schneidende Filme? Nein, drei Monate, es ist immer noch 2024. Haben wir schon diese Traumatorien, die wir uns auf den Kopf setzen können? Denkarien, ja. Entschuldigung, ich bin gerade erst aufgetaut.
Haben wir die Denkarien schon, die uns den Film machen?
Nein, es ist wieder drei Monate nur.
Dann friert mich wieder ein!
Das kann man nicht so einfach starten.
Außerdem haben sie nur einmal bezahlt für einen Auftau-Einfrierprozess.
Sie sind knickerig, Herr Kanz, knickerig.
Geizhals nennen wir sie hier.
Immer wenn wir an ihrer Kryptokammer vorbeigekommen haben, haben wir gesagt, haben wir so leicht zu uns gemurmelt, Geizhals. Geiz kann's. Wo sind die Menschen eingefroren? Was sind das für Orte? In Palo Alto wahrscheinlich. Palo Alto. Palo Alto, ganz irgendwo, wo es ganz kalt ist. Unter der Erde ist ja kalt, relativ kühl. Also ich habe ja lange im Keller gelebt, herrlich, wirklich herrlich. Im Sommer, im Winter zu kalt. Super kühl, herrlich, wunderbar, kein Problem. Aber zu kalt ist kein Problem, Decke, schöne Wolldecke, wickelst du einfach drumherum, kein Problem. Ich bin kein Kellerkind. Als Jim Schoen ist es einmal die Heizung bei uns aufgefallen, es war wirklich fucking kalt. Die Heizung ist aufgefallen, weil sie negativ aufgefallen, weil sie ist ausgefallen. und dann habe ich echt überlegt, ob ich nicht in meinem Zimmer ein Feuer machen soll. Ich war so verzweifelt, dass ich überlegt habe, ist das, also, Gott sei Dank lebst du noch. Kann man ja mal so sagen.
Das haben ja Menschen früher gemacht, die dann einfach gesagt haben, pass auf, wir machen jetzt ein Feuer neben unserem Bett, wir leben zu neunzehnt in einem Zimmer und machen Feuer an.
Du hast gerade rausgenickt, aber wir sind im fünften Stock, da ist niemand. Auf der Feuertreppe steht und wirklich herzlich auch lange zu uns hier reinguckt. Ich sehe niemanden, wir sind im fünften Stock. Das ist Hamburg einfach, wir sind hier einfach Gäste. Stefan ist einfach zu Gast hier und deswegen sind wir hier auch mal so ein bisschen undercover so dabei. Da wird man schon mal angeglotzt auch so ein bisschen da, das sind das für Zugereiste, Herbeigerufene hier. Palo Alto heisst doch Palo Alto, weil Alto hoch ist, nicht? Alto, ja. Alto ist hoch, tief. War das nicht so der, ich glaube, das war das erste Mal, wo ich gedacht habe, Latein ist zurechtgestorben. Hochtief heisst es nicht. Hoch tief heisst beides. Ja, hoch tief. Und dann war es so, Entschuldigung, Herr Lehrer, Magister, Magister, Audite, Audite, eine Frage, Questionare. Questionare! Questionare! Und alle Völkerbälle auf dich drauf, das will ich sehen. Wie kann es denn gleichzeitig hoch und tief heißen? Also ein Beispiel, es heisst jetzt im Text, Katull, der Berg ist tief, wie tief, wie hoch, ich weiss es nicht, question, questionare, caput, est, caputo, in, caputo, est. Und heisst irgendwie Trinkulum, traurig und glücklich. Also haben diealter, du wirst wahrscheinlich innerhalb von 30 Minuten, wenn du dich einer Stadt näherst, deinen gesamten Körperinhalt auskotzen und oder abkoten, weil da so viele Krankheitserreger und Keime in der Luft sind, dass du wahrscheinlich schon nur beim Anblick an irgendeiner Form von Zivilisation so brutal krank bist, dass du den Durchfall deines Lebens hast und erbrichst, wie du dich noch nie erbrochen hast. Okay, weil ich habe jetzt schon halt sehr viel, also hilft Immunium akut? Überhaupt nicht, nein. Das würde wahrscheinlich dein geschundenes Immunsystem noch weiter schicken. Also ich war extra bei meinem Reisearzt und er hat mich geimpft für die herkömmlichsten Krankheiten. Kennen Sie diese Rasensprenger, die so mehr so wo so klar die kenne ich natürlich so aus so verschiedenen Strahlen. Ich habe noch keine Ahnung, wo das hingeht, diese Metapher. Ne genau, klar, ich falle in die Falle, weil ich ja die kenne ich. Kennen Sie das, kennen Sie das? Und so ähnlich würden Sie als Körper aussehen, wenn Sie diese Richtigung habe ich nicht kommen. Aus jeder einzelnen Körperöffnung. Stellen stellen Sie sich eine galärtartige braune Masse vor, die aus jeder einzelnen ihrer Körperöffnungen schiesst, Ohren, Augen, Anus, in alle Richtungen. Wir sind immer noch Punkt eins. Punkt zwei, wenn sie alleine reisen, werden sie wahrscheinlich innerhalb von vier, fünf Minuten ausgeraubt werden, weil es keine Polizei gibt, es gibt kein gültiges Rechtssystem, keine Chance. Man hat mir so einen Taser gegeben. Die Menschen damals haben keinen Strom geleitet. Das ist auch noch ein Ding. Die haben einfach keinen Strom geleitet, weil damals gab es keinen Strom. Aber so eine Ritterrüstung, glaube ich, ist nicht so, nein? Da haben sie einen Gambeson darunter, dann leitet das nicht. Das ist ja wie ein faradelscher Käfig. Das ist von Dank den Kar käfig so dank den karium der plattenrüstung träger ist ja besonders geschützt vor elektrizität ich verstehe nur jibberisch faradaischer käfig gehen sie mal ins deutsche museum so also sie werden innerhalb kürzer zeit sich einfach tot defekieren todkoten und das was Was von ihnen übrig blieb, wird ausgeraubt und umgemacht nur noch fragen und dann sieben uhr aufstehen morgen oder genau okay ja im grunde war das tatsächlich erthe noch aber ich mag die ich mag diese zeitreise geschichte weil eigentlich ja ich hätte meine in der serienidee eigentlich wollte ich mal machen aber nie wer spielt die hauptrolle die du es so ein Zeitreisebüro, so ein Beta-Tester von so einem Zeitreisebüro, die erste Gruppe, die ihn dann loslegt und so ein bisschen halt so Westworld-Style und dann hieß es die Serie? Du fühlst dich falsch an. Westworld? Ja, genau. Ja, und dann kommt man halt in so einen riesen Fundus, das war inspiriert von der FTA, die Ausstattung in Köln, die Filmausstattung und es ist einfach eine riesen halle wo so meter hoch einfach regale stehen mit allen dingen und ich fand die vorstellung so toll dass auch so kostüme dass es einfach authentische mittelalter kostüme sind und du wirst halt sozusagen von einem so apple mitarbeiter artigen menschen wirst du halt bekommst du eine rolle zugeteilt und lernst das. Über Wochen lernst du diese Rolle anzunehmen, kriegst ein Kostüm, eine Backstory mit Autoren, die kommen zu dir und überlegen sich eine Backstory. Und dann wirst du halt, damit es authentisch ist und um die Leute da nicht zu verstören. Also aus ethischen Gründen. Und dann wirst du in eine Stadt geschickt, von der man weiss, dass sie nie Einfluss hatte auf den Rest. Weil zu dieser Zeit, diese eine Woche, in der man da ist, diese eine Woche hat keinen Einfluss auf den Rest, weil die ganze Stadt danach gestorben ist an der Pest. Und niemand hat das verlassen. Heißt, das ist so ein closed circle und da kann man reinreisen, man soll aber nicht mit der Burgfräulein schlafen, zum Beispiel nicht schlafen. Weil das könnte Dinge verursachen, das wissen wir nicht. Und auch aus ethischen Gründen. Aber okay, das ist weitergeinteressiert mich gar nicht. Ich interessiere nur eine andere. Ich finde es super. Und deswegen habe ich es dir gegeben. Ja, perfekt. Und vor allem sind es Leute, so eine coole Gruppe Menschen, so junge Leute, die einfach so die Beta-Tester sind, die irgendwie Preise ausschreiben gewonnen oder sind die Tochter von der Reisebüroleiterin, was auch immer. Und dann kommen die in diese Halle und kriegen Backstories und dann geht die Reise los, wenn im Mittelalter Abspannflotten ist happy. Oder du kriegst, ich überlege mir noch, weil du musst ja dann zwei Wochen trainieren und du willst ja einfach nur zum Spaß hin, du willst einfach nur mal Mittelalter erleben und so, einfach wie so eine Reise. Und dann aber kurz am Tag, wo es losgehen soll, ja, elf Uhr werde ich abgeholt, sieben Uhr ruft der Pfadverleiter an und sagt, es geht erst um dreizehn Uhr los. Um sieben Uhr an dem Tag klopft jemand an der Tür. Ja, herein, Tür ist offen. Okay, die Tür öffnet sich, eine vermummte Gestalt kommt herein. Ein Pudi über dem Kopf. Was machen Sie bei einer Wohnung? Hier, für Sie, es ist wichtig. Und überreicht dir ein Pergament, eine Pergamentrolle. Eine Pergamentrolle? Dabei leben wir im Jahr? 2018. Okay, okay, weird. Und da steht drauf, niemals in die Zerpfergange reisen. Wird aufgerollt und da steht drauf Auftrag. Du musst diesen und jeden Schäfer töten in dieser Stadt, ansonsten geht die Welt unter. Und das Schaf Gerry. Und das Schaf Gerry musst du, du musst reinschreiben in das Fell Habemus Papam. Und dann hast du natürlich die gesamte Zeit, du gehst da hin und alle, ah, schön, dass sie da sind für unsere time experience und alles super suchen die leute im dorf aber nein bei dem apple mässigen laden da und die hauptfigur die ganze zeit egal ich hab einfach spaß ich hab einfach spaß ich vergesse die vermute gestalt in meinem wohnzimmer ich vergesse die prämisse der serie egal habe ich meine tür ich meine Tür abgeschlossen. Ich vergesse die Prämisse.
Und dann aber kann die Person nicht so wirklich Spaß haben, weil sie denkt, ah, habe ich nicht eine Schicksalsantwortung. Macht sie es dann oder nicht, weil es ist doch alles vielleicht ein zusammenhängender Kreis. Ja, klar, natürlich. Ich finde die Frage noch spannend, hat diese Stadt vielleicht doch Einfluss auf die Zukunft? Aber das klären wir in der nächsten Folge des Podcasts UFO oder in der Serie und ich freue mich sehr darauf, wie wir diesen Pfaden mit Sie dann wieder aufnehmen werden.
Ich liebe Klepfänger, mach's gut, hat einen schönen Abend, noch ein, bis zur sechs Woche.